I wasn't familiar with Olivia Wilde
before this story came out incel Gods
Jordan Peterson was the basis for don't
worry darling bad guy I don't understand
how you could align Jordan Peterson's
approach for men and I've watched a lot
of his stuff there isn't a single time
that I can remember where he's placed
the blame of the ineffectiveness of men
in the dating Market at their own feet
always said well you better pull those
bootstraps up Buckle his message on this
is against the incel excuse what is the
inside excuse and how does Jordan's
message diverge from what they typically
believe so intels typically believe in
what's called black pill thinking taking
the black pill as it kind of describes
that it was hopeless from the beginning
and that there's nothing incels could do
to change their romantic Prospect
whereas that's antithesis of Jordan
Peterson's message his idea is you can
always tilt the world one way or the
other to say that he's like an incel
King and kind of fortifies their world
view actually the more in cells that
would take his message seriously they'd
probably benefit from it you know incel
God not in cell